now welcome to this video about the bill
tournament which has just started
yesterday in bill Switzerland and we've
got a nice interesting um yeah field of
players that's a six-player event which
will be a double round-robin so all play
all two times and we've got magnus
carlsen playing the world's number one
when we corona camera of the US always
interesting chest from him so very nice
um then legs and I'm Milosevic from
Russia was always welcome addition to
any tournament because it's such a
creative player you never know what you
get young it's quite like this line from
Forrest Gump young and had box of
chocolates but you never know what
you're going to get he's playing
brilliantly at x and y am very weird and
other occasions so I'm interesting
player and we've got one half from China
I think China's number one player also
quite an enterprising player then we've
got each in back row from France was
thinking maybe a little bit yeah of an
underestimated player he's 2700
something for for ages and he earns it
mostly due to yea big open tournaments
oh it's not at all easy to keep such
high rating and then we also got onions
Gary from from the Netherlands one of
the top junior players already 2,700
yellow at age no need to think I think
it's turning 18 this year so yeah great
talent um and I didn't do anything on
the first round yesterday I didn't
simply didn't at the time they were also
interesting games the first round we had
a draw between cars in a locker
where Magnus was maybe very slightly
better but didn't materialize it wasn't
anything substantial we had one how
beating a back row and interesting
fighting Kings Indian and moroso which
lost with white against giri who just
has one had wonder the dash championship
which is not a whit not a week
tournament he had won the Dutch
championship without six out of seven or
something the huge score so I think he's
seems to be in good shape so but let's
get right to the seven second round
played today and this also had an
interesting games we had to draw between
replica camera and and geary and two
decisive games between cards 9 10 and
also back row m vs some morose ovitch so
let's get to this games i start with
cards and Wang Hao and Marlins playing
deform and we gotta get a new missile
here which carls now I'm replies to
Quincy two castles yeah i'd hear them by
far most popular muth is just a three
and shall we get something along this
like playing b6 here or d5 just the the
mainline year of the Quincy too but
Magnus play something else he plays 93
which is a sideline you're very often
employs though somewhat semi common
moves to a really young yeah play chess
or leave and not so much get into a
theoretical battle when how now plays b6
which i think is quite a surprise I was
surprised and I looked looked this up
late in the data better this is actually
a move that has been played them quite a
lot by even really good players because
at first sight I would say it's just a
just a mistake this move but it is
played um the main move here is by far
c5 which normally continued so long this
year
then it continues further white can play
and g3 rc6 is an interesting move yet
this is championed by melrose which
played this couple of times but okay one
how 144 b6 here and this allows e4 and
this is why I'm surprised that this move
was playable because you really should
try to prevent white from setting up
this huge center here but maybe it's
it's playable okay he went bishop LOL c5
okay this is another deviation here um
which actually leads to a different kind
of position then there should be seven
which is in a sight line the more common
move usually continues like this year
and although this is a mistake sorry um
should be three and then now c5 I guess
well this is this Bishop e7 has been
played um more often oh no XD five sorry
I'm confused here it's d5 l'd should
move over here d 5 e 594 we should be
three and Bishop resemblances this has
been played a couple of times but also
looks very nice for white if you ask me
so quite a strange opening choice by
long haul on he won't see five now um
which Magnus some answered with a
quickie five which is quite strong I
think and I'll black gown retreated to
e8 um he had the alternative to capture
and before but this is very nice for
white I'm with more than one possible
way to get an advantage the simple way
would be just to take here and play this
move yep like blacks Rukia is some
detect on a eight so he needs to do
something about this this is the only
way to to save it and now what can take
and it's it's not so good to capture on
c6 black gets lots of developing but
he can just develop a piece of seven
white white is better here with this
this strong porn on oops I need let's
make the screen with this with this pawn
here on 95 this is a very nice spearhead
and the night on the eighth is just a
sorry piece so I'm this is one
possibility of Blackwood on e5 capture
on d4 body plate 98 yeah now Magnus just
played d5 grabbing this huge center here
with the spawn do here very nice so
white is a nice space advantage okay
black plays this caption here nd6 to get
his some his fish about him and detect
the center on Bishop g5 quite a logical
answer just attacking the Queen and
well-liked has doesn't have any good
moves with this Queen so on he plays f6
which also helps getting the night here
back into play only eight it wasn't a
great piece but one thing which is
apparent here White House has also got
this this nice pin here on the on the
Queen and he will play Bishop b3 at some
point and then set up this battery on
the kingside black only has got those
two kings iPhones at the shelter for
asking and he is quite weekend e six
this week this whole white squares and
now we've got a nice picture here maybe
I can sell this is more a lot yeah well
black has a wicking side and we'll see
that in the game exploited very nicely
okay here Magnus just casts of long
getting the King out of the center and
yeah getting development going why does
also I just better developed here
okay captured now and because it was
also a possibility if like it doesn't
capture that white simply move to the
night let's say black would make sort of
an semi move something like this here
then you need to reckon with stuff like
this here or maybe even this and well
this is bishop p.m. runs just points
into thin air now and to some maybe even
yeah in danger of getting trapped at
some point not immediately but it's an
it's an option so on he decided to
immediately capture this night makes
sense I guess and now develop this
Bishop you had the problem with this
move is this this Bishop didn't have a
good square really and here on g4 the
only purpose on g4 really is to to take
on f3 and this happens in the game you
see what what kind of position yeah like
a play black is getting to be honest I
think black is already a.m. yeah in some
trouble here if you look at it with the
computer and the computer actually the
census the Sun is about equal but I
don't don't agree I think like us really
in trouble in the long run I mean maybe
a computer computer is very cool and
defending obviously it's got no nerves
but um like really AM gets into into
some yeah defensive travel see and we'll
see young rookie one first a good move
to to control the open file and yeah
maybe threatened to move this night so
he gets out of the pin if what would be
able to move the night away then you
might chase the bishop with all kinds of
moves on the night might go to c4 so
like a sort of yeah forced into
capturing here or at least tempted to do
so
and TM well we see a very interesting
and yeah uneven position where white has
an absolutely awful structure I mean
everything's isolated looks like Swiss
cheese here this this bone structure but
he's got brilliant bishops this one has
got a nice pin going this Bishop is
going here like his Flex position is
really a full of holes and white is got
to the gphone so I think white is very
very much to be preferred here so we see
what happens lat BTW salmon we should be
three just threatening here using the
pin on the on the night f6 and black is
provoked to move this pawn okay and this
of course is a point of technologies h6
pawn white retreats taking both pawn cm
and ce4 yeah very understandable black
wants to distract wide a bit and
activate its night of course why doesn't
take on c4 this doesn't make much sense
to give likely the open sea file he just
plays here and gets this idea into the
game we should be 695 and rook g1 yeah I
think this is a position that yeah well
maybe maybe a computer can help this but
for human against yeah the world's
number one player at CERN it's just them
it's just useless the smells like
execution and Magnus does nice job p.m.
King edge 8th route g6 piling up on h6
look f7 yeah and he plays a good move
group 2 g1 but in this position um there
was actually a even more forceful move
but
it was um it was difficult really to to
calculate this in this position wyd
already had the possibility to capture
on H sticks this was playable I'm not
quite sure maybe he he didn't calculate
this this correctly I wrote you one was
perfectly fine i just i just want to
show it because it can lead to two nice
lines black captures here take him and
yeah now black actually is forced to
play this move and this obviously is
something that yeah that looks that
looks nice for white but now i look at
now looking at this it's maybe not so
super clear black will play something
like this here and yeah maybe he'll
maybe has some chances to defend this
the thing is white has 112 points here
but the pawns are so bad that white has
and it's no mate that's no made maybe
this isn't so clear now it's possible
that you saw this but rejected it i
think that the tricky line wasn't 9h 7
but but but King g8 this was the line
which surprised me that this is actually
completely winning chopped rooted g1
here and here's your check quite a quite
a nasty czech take some g7 King takes
Queen chair here here and this is
completely winning for what he's just
got a winning attack I don't know maybe
he didn't calculate this correctly or he
rejected this because of the other line
where white has got two extra pawns but
it's not not winning immediately what he
did was absolutely fine he just played
Rock g1 and putting more pressure on
this I mean this is usually a very good
strategy if you I've got such an
overwhelming position
you should look really far for
completely yeah devastating strike not
just an extra porn but really trying to
do to push push black of the body em and
he may be just want what to increase the
pressure even more very possible Queen
f8 was played to to get more cover on g7
you should to e3 and this is a mover
like very much of course on f4 this
Bishop always had this possibility but
on deform it's just a brilliant piece
striking down this long diagonal and
really getting everything on the king I
mean really understand the bishop is
just perfect I like this there should be
three a lot think it's very good move 95
and now he played them bishop t form in
this position also bishop age six was a
possibility and also why could have
taken on c5 which is on the
materialistic way of playing we can you
can go something like this year but
maybe this wasn't wasn't enough for four
white this kind of position here you
look at this is possibly I mean white is
certainly winning but maybe this this
actually wasn't enough for him stuff
like this maybe okay what he did was
just yeah sort of clinical way to to to
play it he just played this move Knight
back to to cover cover this and then
Queenie to intending to shift the Queen
over a black and cannot possibly hold
this it's just it just too much all
pieces on the King as too much
black played rookie ATM and now rook g7
white strikes here the idea being
inflated queen here Queen takes 3-7 but
idea of course of the rook takes then
you grab here and i think it's it's even
a checkmate in a couple of moose and say
here yeah everything's pinned here yeah
this this already isn't made with Queen
f6 so he couldn't take what the rook so
needed to take with the Queen and now I
just grab the Queen retakes and queen a
form yeah the Queen joins the attack
possibly young intending checks here or
here even when G formats it's a pin
after all very strong one and white also
threatens the spawn it's still a huge
attack and this bishops really a raging
down the board very nicely social egg
decides to get rid of one of the bishops
it's the tag of course and now just
simply King be too wide wants to get rid
of this pawn and then it's got an extra
porn and this dominating Bishop with
blacks King just being a terribly open
here and yeah it it works nicely for
right now each for is another strong
move using everything in the attack here
porn site attacking units also and this
age bone is quite a strong attacking
unit we see immediately like place
rookie seven and note that both players
were already is lower down down on time
check out the strong move h5 this is
really nice not difficult to see but
it's still nice the black would take
with the night now gender simply this
move with a check and what once the
night next move
yeah if he takes with the king then yeah
what can can just take here if you want
or first let's check it's also not bad
at all so until picking off i'll be
picking up off clicks pieces so this is
just winning it cannot take on age 5 you
need to retreat and then the Queen and
just the picture like plate to Rocky 5
trying to yeah second exchange here but
white can first give this check and play
a stronger move than taking the exchange
just their form and this is just
devastating the rook is attacked by poor
now and where should it go you go rook
air-five this yeah this looks a bit
artificial and at least this is possible
group takes a check King needs to go
here to keep the root protected so then
f4 and white windsor the rook yeah very
nice attacking display after an f4 here
on one Hal resigned yeah very nice fight
also between structure for black and
dynamics for white but I mean the porn
structures it's nice to have but if
you've got all your pieces on the king
it's just yeah it's just not possible to
play in such a way hard to pinpoint like
exactly went wrong but if you ask me
this kind of structure here is some it's
just terrible even if the computer says
it's fine but I don't believe it yes
among awesome were the wind today on
going yeah to the lead in this
tournament but this wasn't the only
interesting game today the other
decisive game was back row against
Norwich and I'll show you this one and
if you like the Carlton game as
if you like attacking chess you like the
cards and game i guess but look at this
this is really a roller coaster right
here okay acro play Steve front and
we've got the sense love triangle set up
with e6 and c6 I think this is a very
interesting move order for black it's
only got one drawback really and this is
the movie form which engine see
interestingly it's not played so often
then white players often shy away from
this move it involves a pawn sacrifice
and it's not like people don't want a
sec cause once in a while but this is
really a super complicated line and it's
very hard to memorize the stuff
especially considering that this
triangle setup for black isn't played so
often so you need to learn really lots
of stuff for a line that you yeah
probably don't get gets off in your
games so let's see what happens
monogrammed grabbed only forth and hate
this check and now we see the spawn sack
white could retreat the night but this
is somewhat of a Wimpy move in a way
it's not bad but it's not the idea of
all this the idea is to play this Bishop
b2 move well here black really doesn't
have much of a choice he he could
capture on g2 but this should be quite
nice for white still the c8 bishop as an
issue and white has a nice center here
so the thing is on Bishop e2 black grabs
the pawn or deform the juicy central
pawn but what's the consequence wyd take
on before so and black wrap tonight so
here white has two moves 92 Bishop e2
and tickles we should be too now so
let's take stock for a while what does
white half for his pawn he's got an
immensely strong Bishop Ian
which makes it very very hard for black
to ever Castle blacks very weak on the
dark squares those squares are quite
quite a problem and black has got this
is weird Queen on any form which yeah
can be an object of attack for white
ones even Mort mp4s attack but also can
somehow disrupt white this whole line is
some very yeah very hotly debated it's
very difficult to come to a conclusion
in a recent book by a grandmaster Ruslan
Shabak off about the triangle system be
analyzed this line for very you have a
very long time I don't know it was 200
pages or something and it's very hard to
to get grabs on to this very difficult
um erosa which now played 96 which is
one of the main moves maybe the most
popular one here white um even has got
some alternatives um he can play he
plays this move but he can play as some
other stuff also possible as this year
with the not too subtle threat Queen yet
mate whitey evenings got the the funny
option of playing this move if it's
quite quite nice if you have a nephew
never saw this it looks quite funny
there there are stories about players
being asked what the hell are you doing
you need to put a black Bishop on evade
yeah the idea of course being a few of
you like takes the minute it's a check
made on d 8 and of course yeah simply
this point of threatened okay don't want
to make a theoretical lesson about this
just to show you should've ate because
it's a funny move he went on when 26
which is certainly logical still
preventing short castle and also if flag
should cancel long
this piece alone is just great I mean I
would absolutely never play this as
black but maybe a matter of taste also
okay so moral now grab down g2 which is
super risky on there there are other
possibilities but ok this I don't want
to go too much into the theoretical
stuff here what now place Queen d2 and
yeah well wait a minute what about the
look on each one yeah black actually
cannot take the rook if you if you would
do so white can play long castle and the
problem is here white threatens the
simple move oops no this way Bishop e3
enter the queen is strapped so black
cannot play let's say something like
this yeah you just get your queen
trapped and if black wants to solve
evacuate this piece then white plays
this funny move and wellness is
checkmate no way for black to prevent
this besides some silly stuff like a 25
or something like it's just made it here
so what this means is black cannot grab
the rook you played the interesting
movie 5 here sort of yeah giving back a
born possibly only five but opening up
the diagonal for the bishop white grab
this a black played Bishop f5 quite
illogical have this this Bishop now also
has got a good good position white
gained the tempo here on the Queen Queen
[ __ ] didn't have her any other
squares and now long castle so you can
see that white really has compensation
for the for the pawn no doubt about it I
still got strong bishops and
let's put put the next moves on the
board 95 yeah probably intending stuff
like this query 3 yeah now if you look
look at this kind of stuff on g7 and
white really has a really nice
initiative um Marissa which now plays
really yeah ambitious is gavin's very
ambitious inflate we should be one just
threatening mate in one move and okay
white needs to attend to this kavitha
and now black rat on on a two so a very
cheeky way to play this of course in the
meantime also menacing stuff like this
and end this year so wyd needs to react
to to this of course he gave this check
yeah and what what should like to this
night is also hanging and you cannot
move the King so you need to drop the
night bag i no white can play be sure
before covering the sensitive square
where the meat were threatened tweenage
6 + f4 yeah and now why it has got four
pawns black 60 white has sacrificed to
bonds but of course he's still super
active here if you give this to the
computer it tells you about yeah that
this position is around equal and this
is already a sure sign that black has
problems in a position where black is
two points up the computer says is equal
this is very suspicious he had tried to
develop a piece at least 9 f 6 and 9 a-3
speeding up your own development and
black wrapped another part so three
points now
and yeah well the problem is simply
you've got a king in the middle and you
cannot evacuate this piece if you would
cancel long you've got a seven also
hanging and short castle well this is
against the rules of the game it's just
very difficult to defend this position
but one thing look at the clocks back
row five minutes left and Mauro was 37
minutes so what white didn't have much
time still rookie one improving the
position further all pieces should join
the attack and black castle long now yet
here wide really with five minutes on
the clock yeah decided to strike he just
took on c6 really a strong move but also
move that actually allows black now to
get to draw the game in a way but like
now did is played the bishop e6 but
black had the opportunity he could also
just take here the the obvious move and
then after Queen a seven black could
play rook checks d6 and here i think i'm
white needs to be content with the draw
white can draw his queen a a check King
c7 you cannot go here so this check
needs to meet at the end even you must
believe me I don't want to put it on the
board it's it's just just a complete
complete disaster rooks a queen a king a
c7 and then kuzey 7 and it really is the
draw she would go here you allow just
this check so black goes here and you
have a perpetual perpetual Czechia so
black with them taking on 26 the simple
move technology 6 could have drawn the
game but he played
should be six and well now what really
gets going him he plays 95 and he played
this with really low time on the clock
and this move now is winning the game
like is not able to to to save the
position now whatever he plays some he
will be a yeah mate it on like will lose
ya was the modes of material what he did
play at the end is to capture on g5 it
didn't make much difference and the
clock is all so weird here of course he
didn't overstep the time yeah but now
look at this position it's really quite
quite funny you have those two nice
bishops and widest got this tremendous
power on the central files so just think
I've hit the Run button see I want to
get rid of the arrows look at this
position I give you a couple of seconds
and we'll stop the video for a couple of
seconds to look for a good move for YTM
let them I let let a couple of seconds
pass iam don't tell you the move and use
as a nice kind of exercise all right
i'll show it now white now played Bishop
d7 check and this is of course very very
nice 52 di giving a check on a square
which is defended by the rook by the
night and the king and whatever black
does it it's checkmate at the end very
nice he took in the game he took with
with a king but if he takes with the
night You certainly have this check here
and well I can do those kind of shocked
silly talk desperados and FDNY's it's
made only seven quite nice
so cannot take with the night so the
other line if you take with the rook
chak chak here king here check on e 7
yeah note the rook here black cannot
cannot take on these seven king moves
yeah rook militant checkmate also quite
nice so yeah this Bishop d7 move really
was a hammer blow like needed to take
care I mean okay it's made anyway but he
took with the king you took with the
king and then I Queenie sound check king
here chak chak here and now I'm arose
which resigned in view of King b5 only
move chak chak chak need and will be for
check so wyd really flushed the black
king out in the open and gift jeff chang
medion before so this move Bishop this
one was really nice very aesthetic
started leap really pleasing move um but
of course quite weird hear that
Milosevic shown with lots of time on the
clock um didn't didn't see a 95
obviously I could have simply simply
drawn the game with taking on c6 yeah I
mean simply I think it did for player of
such class it's pretty pretty easy to
calculate this a draw and yeah me
suddenly wanted after losing yesterday
wanted to try something in this game but
ok at one point there's a point in each
game where you need to be honest to
yourself you can just draw and then you
need to do it there's no way to to to do
otherwise maybe it was a gamble on
White's time travel I don't know but it
allowed a very nice meeting finish here
yeah right so um we had a look at those
22 games off today I hope you enjoyed it
quite some cool attacking chess
would say um yeah 2 i'll be doing some
some more stuff on on bill in the next
coming days but maybe due to work
restraints and other things maybe not be
able to do it every day but if they're
there are some some interesting games
I'll make sure that the beyond the
channel in a way right thanks for
watching and see you soon and talk to
you soon in a new video